at least 78 people are known to have
been killed in a stampede at an event to
distribute financial aid in the yemeni
capital dozens more were injured after
hundreds of people gathered for what was
described as a random distribution of
cash
now the crush took place in The Old City
uh in hundreds of people had gathered at
a school there now Witnesses say that uh
armed houthi Rebels fired into the air
in an attempt at crowd control but they
hit an electric cable which caused it to
explode resulting in panic and the
Stampede now people had gathered to
receive around ten dollars each from a
charity funded by local businessmen
the interior Ministry has blamed the
crush on the random distribution of
funds without coordination it said in a
statement that two Merchants responsible
for organizing the donation have been
detained and an investigation is
underway